president biden playing the part on
april fools boasting about what he calls
a booming economy but little does he
know the joke is on him biden claims
everything's going just great but even
the left-wing media won't defend him
politico warning about biden's sophomore
slump
with the president failing on just about
every single issue you have to give joe
some credit
despite his dumpster fire presidency he
sure knows how to spin things
it's very clear
america are back to work
our policies are working and we're
getting results for the american people
we need to do more to get prices under
control
putin's invasion of ukraine has driven
up gas prices and food prices all over
the world was the previous
administration whose reckless policies
and mismanagement led to the record
budget deficits
in my administration that's getting the
deficit under control
and sadly it gets worse the biden
administration continues to prove how
clueless and out of touch they really
are
like their solution to the energy crisis
telling everybody just to go out and buy
electric cars that they can't even
afford
we can take advantage of the next
generation of electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about
eighty dollars a month from not having
to pay gas at the pump i know electric
vehicles can be expensive at the at the
but it's one of the reasons why the
president wants to see those those
tax credits to bring down the price at
the dealer so that people can buy
electric vehicles and don't have to ever
worry about going to fill it up at the
gas pump even if all of the oil we use
in the usa were made in the usa
the price of it is still subject to
powers and dynamics outside of the usa
digging why can't we do both why can't
administration officials come out and
just say we'll do a little bit of fossil
fuel we'll do a little bit of green and
everybody say fine let's go
uh because they're ideologues and they
have no connection to real world
consequences or facts so when it comes
to people and their pain instead of well
you know i feel that this is hurting you
it's suck it up that's why
ideologues dictating policy is so
dangerous and harmful number one they
could come out with a giant plan but
this is the policy on energy is as
incoherent as joe biden himself
annie lippau
my go-to guy on energy analysis said the
strategic petroleum reserve release is a
one-time measure to bridge a supply
disruption but does nothing to get more
supplies out of the ground to replace
russian supplies that was in the wall
street journal so
why is joe biden castigating and
vilifying and putting the hammer down on
our own energy producers
and then he alienated saudi arabia
stopped backing and funding the war on
the iran-backed houthis by saudi arabia
saudi arabia the united arab emirates
and kuwait combined have enough spare
production to offset the oil and then
some that's come off the market because
of russia biden needs that iran nuke
deal
but it's
yes we really need the iran movement and
then he's begging venezuela and iran uh
for for more oil rather than saudi
arabia who won't even pick up his ring
of ding ding the crown prince so
so what's going on is he is
destroying our prosperity and i'm
damaging our standard of living rather
than um siding with our energy producers
now just add one more thing
he's got to stop telling people to buy
electric cars if uh president paltrown
had had one foot in the real world in
the last 50 years he would know that we
love to drive we're a car country and
you never tell anybody not even your
spouse what kind of vehicle to buy that
is a good point and biden himself
doesn't even own an electric car
he owns one of these muscle cars no he
said but you guys are just being too
hard on him we are you know i mean he
said and i i just heard him say that you
you're going to save 80 a month
if you get an electric car so i did the
math it's gonna take me
a hundred years
eighty dollars a month to afford that
electric car so i'm actually i don't
know i'm actually gonna have to go back
in time
and buy and start start saving in order
to do this it's very by the way it's 80
bucks a month that's an understatement
in in the biden inflation it's more like
80 bucks a week is what we're paying i
also take issue with politico i think it
was unfair to joe biden to call it a
sophomore slump because that implies he
had a good freshman year right a slump
you know it says
if it's been downhill from day one
there's no slump it's just a a slow roll
to armageddon
um and i i am wondering where all the
never trumpers are right now who said
that anything was better than trump
are you sure i mean come on i know the
mean tweets they made you sad at night
you couldn't sleep the psychological
damage is there your ptsd over his
over his insults were just too hard to
take but you got he got inflation you
got crime
i mean
come on any politicos on the slump too
judge they were like oh the president he
can't do that much with inflation you
know you can't make mansion do
everything so it's not all joe's fault
yeah well they got it right he can't do
much that's the end of the sentence
period uh but you know what amazes me
about this electric car thing is that
they want everyone to buy one right and
they want to they want to give
money and subsidize the car
manufacturers so we don't get money to
buy the car the car manufacturers get
money so that they can sell it a little
cheaper so that we can buy it i mean
that's what they're doing and they're
doing it right in front of us and you
know the saddest part of all this is
that every senior citizen watching this
show right now who is who lives on a
fixed income and can barely afford to
keep his or her car
up to date and pay for gas can't even
think about an electric car and my final
point is you know the battery someone
mentioned this to me the other day the
batteries for electric cars you know the
ones that are made of lithium from
afghanistan that we get from china hey
joe you don't have a connection to china
do you your son hunter wasn't involved
in china was he no i got it wrong i'm
sure do you know how big those batteries
are they are huge when you get rid of
that electric car what do you do with
that hazardous waste you and your green
energy pals joe yeah what do we do with
all that battery acid jessica
i think we blame hunter biden yes we'll
be right back about the vibe
um so i've been taking notes seriously
on everything i want to touch one greg
you can afford an electric car today
i'm talking about the viewer at home uh
it's not about me jessica how dare you
okay so the reason that we heard from
joe biden today is because we had a
really great jobs report but no one else
has mentioned that and even oh
it was short by 60 000. we it was good
she said it
it was good and i'm honest i dispute it
we're gonna run out of time i gotta get
that was my goal so
we have a 3.6 unemployment rate which is
nearing the 50-year low that's a really
big deal that we've gotten there that
doesn't mean that inflation isn't a
problem by the way it's a global problem
this is not a problem that only the
united states is having but we're seeing
which i find really interesting as a
democratic voter a real fissure between
what's going on with biden and what's
going on with moderate democrats running
across the country and the question now
will be if people running on the
congressional level in these moderate
districts like abigail spanberger alisa
slotkin et cetera who's now even
supporting legislation about securing
the border and she does have a national
security background so that's important
to that will be running ahead of the
president and so i'm not saying that i
think the democrats are going to win in
november it still obviously looks like a
republican win when you look at the
congressional ballot but
you have to think at this point is it
feasible that democrats will outperform
the president and how often does that
happen throughout history
not that often all right i think
everybody's outperforming the president
right now my dogs he's making
joe biden's making jimmy carter's
administration look better and better
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else